[Musique]
bienvenue un air de printemps souffle
sur cette émission à la une le paris
saclay spring 2021 une troisième édition
qui se déroule sur deux jours et qui
sera donc en forme à 100% digitale
au programme des rencontres des
conférences des journées portes ouvertes
et une multitude de rendez vous tous les
acteurs de l'innovation de la recherche
et de la science
seront présents pour donner à voir
l'excellence scientifique est le
meilleur des innovations technologiques
avec une grande nouveauté cette année le
spring 50 je vous en ai plus dans un
instant rien ne le prédestinait à
devenir un entrepreneur et pourtant
valérie en viennent à sauter le pas ce
chercheur a cofondé candela une start up
spécialisée dans la photonique quantique
un secteur hautement stratégique
rencontre vous allez aussi découvrir une
pépinière transitoire de 1800 arbres
implantés sur le quartier de corbeil
ville des espèces qui vont croître qui
vont pousser qui seront ensuite
réimplanter sur l'ensemble du territoire
et enfin un manège éphémère pour
remobiliser sur le front de l'emploi
il fallait y penser gros plan sur cette
initiative surprenante et enfin notre
agenda
vous savez c'est à la fin de cette
émission
c'est l'événement du printemps le paris
saclay spring revient une troisième
édition riche en rencontres un format
100% digitale deux jours pour découvrir
ou redécouvrir l'excellence scientifique
et le meilleur de l'innovation
technologique de votre territoire et je
vous le disais la grande nouveauté cette
année c'est le spring 50/50 start-up
vont être mises à l'honneur chaque
promotion aura son parrain et pour cette
grande première c'est gary hunt sens
fondateur dolce rixe qui a accepté de
relever le défi
je m'appelle gare est enceinte j'ai 37
ans je suis entrepreneur depuis l'âge de
20 ans pour le truc c'est ma troisième
entreprise que j'ai fondée en 2008
alors je suis loin d'être tout seul à
présent nous sommes environ 250
collaborateurs spécialisés sur une
plateforme online
historiquement et puis avec un projet
omni canal depuis quelques années autour
du monde du sport et plus précisément du
vélo de la course à pied et de l'outdoor
où nous proposons plus de cent mille
références à 1.5 millions d'utilisateurs
en france et l'autre business se ventile
également à quasiment 25% maintenant à
l'international et donc je suis par
ailleurs co fondateur de la french tech
paris saclay qui était labellisé il ya
un peu plus de deux ans et qui compte
plus d'une centaine de start up sur le
territoire entre massy et versailles en
passant évidemment par le plateau de
paris saclay qui regroupe environ 500
startups et puis j'ai eu le grand
plaisir d'être invité à être parrain de
l'édition spring de 50 de cette année et
je suis évidemment très honorée et très
fière très énergisé est de pouvoir
participer à cet événement qui va mettre
en lumière des start-up que nous avons
donc retenu suite à leur candidature
pour pouvoir les faire briller sur le
plan local national et international et
mettre en lumière leur formidable projet
pour développer relancer énormément
d'activité en france et donc mon rôle
dans cette mission de parent donc c'est
évidemment d'accompagner le casting de
ces entreprises
et puis de les suivre de les coachs et
les mentors est d'échanger avec elle à
la suite de l'événement de spring et de
pouvoir les accompagner dans leur
développement et où ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant et
captivant cette année c'est qu'on voit
énormément de techno de rupture est donc
évidemment dans un contexte comme celui
ci où beaucoup de choses sont en rupture
parce que les modes de vie de
consommation d'interaction sont à
réinventer
il ya énormément de projets
d'entreprises émergentes qui viennent
bousculer challenge et et structurée de
nouveaux sujets et de nouveaux projets
de demain et donc c'est un grand plaisir
pour moi de pouvoir participer à cet
événement fans d'entrepreneuriat comme
je le suis investisseurs modeste dans
une dizaine de start up en parallèle
dole tricks évidemment très heureux de
voir à quel point le
plateau paris saclay et puis le
mouvement de la french tech
en parallèle se développent et
permettent de faire briller toute cette
créativité et maintenant un parcours qui
s'inscrit dans cette dynamique
entrepreneuriale mise en avant par le
paris saclay spring fall hernandez est
un chercheur dans un domaine très pointu
très stratégique la photonique quantique
il a créé sa start up candela start up
qui fait partie du célèbre classement
des 100 start-up ou investir en 2021 du
magazine challenge
rencontre avec ce chercheur
entrepreneurs
quand elle a été créée en fête au centre
de nanosciences et des nanotechnologies
d'universités paris saclay et du cnrs et
donc nous sommes basés sur le plateau de
saclay et nous développons des
ordinateurs un peu spéciaux qu'on
appelle des ordinateurs quantiques qui
sont des ordinateurs qui vont utiliser
toutes les propriétés de la matière de
la mécanique quantique pour développer
de nouvelles techniques de calcul très
puissante le 21 janvier dernier nous
avons reçu le président de la république
emmanuel macron dans nos locaux au
centre de dans l'océan ces
nanotechnologies où il a annoncé
l'ambition française autour du plan
quantique nationale l'ambition de la
france vise à développer
justement toute cette technologie autour
des ordinateurs quantiques autour des
communications et des capteurs quantique
est donc aujourd'hui les grands
instituts comme le cnrs l'université
paris saclay l'inria ca et les startups
comme candela s'organisent pour mettre
en action leurs ambitions nationales
autour du plan quantique annoncée par le
président est donc en gros la france va
investir 1,8 milliard d'euros pour
financer cette ambition française
financer le passage des briques
technologiques qui sont encore des
laboratoires de recherche comme au sein
de l'université paris saclay vers des
applications et c'est exactement ce que
nous faisons chez candela nous
valorisons une technologie qui était
développée au cnrs et université paris
saclay dans le centre de nanosciences et
nanotechnologies pour développer des
ordinateurs quantiques
c'est donc ici en fait on a développé un
premier prototype qui sert à faire des
premiers calculs à partir de quelques
cubique c'est cubique
ce sont en fait des particules de
lumière qu'on appelle des photons donc
c'est vraiment le gras alimentaires de
la lumière et on utilise le photon pour
enregistrer de l'information quantique
dessus et faire des calculs avec
candela est maintenant en train de
suivre un virage nous cherchons à lever
des fonds pour ça qu'on a fait la une de
challenge afin d'augmenter nos équipes
et d'aller plus loin dans le
développement d'un ordinateur quantique
à base de photos notre ambition c'est de
sortir un ordinateur utile avec
plusieurs dizaines de cuite d'ici trois
à quatre ans elle le met sur le marché
en version cloud ou directement chez les
clients avec paris saclay tv vous n'êtes
pas au bout de vos surprises
ou comment passer de la photonique
quantique à une pépinière transitoire
elle a vu le jour sur le campus urbain
de paris saclay et vous la découvre et
1800 ha ont été plantés sur le quartier
de corneville les espèces locales qui
vont croître ou qui vont pousser et qui
seront ensuite réimplanter sur
l'ensemble territoire
rencontre avec ceux qui sont à la
manoeuvre
[Musique]
sur cette opération de la pépinière de
préfiguration de corneville seul paysage
nous sommes le maître d'oeuvre sur cette
opération
donc c'est une opération qui consiste à
fournir des arbres pour le plateau de
saclay dans les différentes phases
d'aménagement qui vont venir dans les
années qui arrivent et donc en fait ce
projet de pépinière
il a vocation déjà à constituer un
paysage transitoire c'est à dire que
pendant que l'aménagement du plateau se
déroule on a déjà une installation d'un
paysage temporaire qui a aussi une
vocation par la suite à fournir les
différents végétaux et et arbres qui
seront plantés sur les espaces futur les
espaces publics de la zac à la fois du
moulon la zac de l'école polytechnique
et la zac de cordes ville sur ce carré
de pépinières on a planté un peu plus de
deux mille sujets qui vont être en
culture pendant deux saisons
le premier arrachage aura lieu en
2023/2024 sur la période hivernale et le
deuxième arrachage et le dernier aura
lieu en 2024 2025
suivent le pépinière et je suis la
personne qui s'occupe de la pépinière
ici qu'on a créée avec le groupe sain
folha le groupe symphonia c5 pépinière
en france qui sont producteurs et qui
essaye de promouvoir l'activité de la
production des arbres et des arbustes et
des plans de dexter en france
l'objectif était qu à terme on est des
arbres qui fascine taille donnée lors de
l'appel d'offres donc on a planté ici
des petits sujets qu'on appelle des
jeunes arbres avec l'objectif de les
faire pousser de les faire grandir en
hauteur en taille de branche et en
taille de tron pour les fournir aux
futurs d'entreprise de paysages ce
travail sur le plateau de saclay
l'objectif de la pépinière et de
produire des arbres dans un milieu assez
similaire à l'endroit où les arbres on
allait donc un milieu où le sol va être
le même que le sol des chantiers entoure
le but de la pépinière c'était de mettre
des essences assise locale
donc on a planté du boulot du phallus
duchesne et de l'érable
c'est des essences qui sont endémiques
de la région et qu'on va essayer de
produire ici et de hordes de beaux
sujets à la taille demandé aux marchés
l'objectif est de produire des végétaux
dans les conditions climatiques
similaires à l'endroit futur les apps
seront plantés pour l'éternité
[Musique]
un manège écologique et éphémère pour
retrouver un emploi une initiative
surprenante elle a été lancé entre
autres par la maison de l'emploi de
l'insertion et de la formation paris
saclay objectif remobiliser nuit de
vendeurs d'emploi ils vont créer ce
manège éphémère que vous pourrez admirer
au festival des gags de disette et 5 et
6 juin prochains un manège écologique de
sa fabrication à son fonctionnement
et comme sa structure est modulable il
pourra être réutilisé pour d'autres
événements sur le territoire regardez
[Musique]
fait partie des trois partenaires qui
ont initié le projet de manège avec alim
actes et la maison de l'emploi et de
l'insertion et de la formation
la messe de paris saclay la finalité de
l'action c'est de construire un manège
pour les guinguettes de l'yvette qui est
un festival qui a lieu depuis trente ans
sur les rives de l'yvette entre
palaiseau et villebon qui accueille
comme ça du public ça peut aller jusqu'à
dix mille personnes sur un week-end et
on s'est dit tiens ce serait bien qu'on
construise un manège pour ce festival
avec avec des gens s'est rapproché de la
mef qui nous a proposé de mettre en
place un dispositif d'insertion de
mobilisation et de remobilisation pour
des demandeurs d'emploi de
de longue durée là c'est le module de
construction il ya deux autres modules
qui sont des mobiles de remobilisation
avec un coach emploi et un module de
découverte des métiers à la fois des
métiers du recyclage mais aussi les
métiers du spectacle vivant et de
l'animation
ce qui est intéressant est ce qui est
vraiment sympa avec ce projet c'est
qu'il a mobilisé énormément de monde
il a intéressé beaucoup d'acteurs
du plateau de saclay à la fois les
acteurs de l'insertion qui ont donné des
matériaux mais aussi les entreprises
comme bouygues construction qui a donné
tout matériel de sécurité
toutes les deux pays on est accueilli la
dent les un bâtiment qui appartient à le
pea donc l'établissement public
d'aménagement du plateau de saclay qui a
aussi trouvé ce projet intéressant et
nous a mis à la disposition ses locaux
pour pouvoir le réaliser
ce sera vraiment un manège écologique du
début jusqu'à la fin de la récupération
du recyclage des matériaux alors à son
fonctionnement
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent vous l'aurez
compris l'événement incontournable de ce
printemps c'est le pari avec les spring
un événement qui se déroule sur deux
jours alors le mât mais il y aura un
plateau télévisé qui va vous permettre
de mieux comprendre comment le modèle
des communautés d'innovation appareils
sac et a pu faire face à la crise et
quel modèle il peut proposer dans le
futur
le 21 mai ne ratez pas les cirques
innovation alors attention c'est
uniquement sur inscription journée
portes ouvertes dans les laboratoires
les centres de recherche privés et aussi
des stands de partenaires c'est
exclusivement sur le salon virtuel en
digital avec possibilité des changes et
durant ces deux jours des rendez vous b
to b et b to fit en digital sont
également proposés plus d'informations
sur notre site un ep aps point fr
la concertation sur la zac gare de
guyancourt saint-quentin quartier des
savoirs est lancé venez participer aux
échanges sur le futur quartier des
savoirs lors des premières balades
urbaines de découverte du site
rendez vous est pris les trois sets et
mai 2021 deux autres rendez vous à ne
pas manquer l'entrepreneur au coeur de
son projet lors de cet atelier vous
découvrirez comment sécuriser votre
projet en quatre questions
c'est le 7 mai en digital toutes les
informations sont sur le site que vous
voyez s'afficher au bas de l'écran vous
êtes créateur fabricant artisans du
territoire avec une pratique responsable
fait découvrir vos réalisations lors de
notre marché et créateurs c'est jusqu'au
17 mai là aussi plus d'informations sur
le site qui s'affiche
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission ne ratez surtout pas le paris
saclay et spring les 20 et 21 mai moi je
vous dis très bientôt
et d'ici là restez informé sur notre
site ep aps points et faire et prenez
soin de vous à très vite
[Musique]